[Music]
we've generally worked on problems by
looking at how can we solve the problem
but that's a very much of fix-it mindset
you know here's a problem and what can
we do to solve it and technology
advances in technology have enabled us
to do that and is that important of
course it is it's necessary but it's not
sufficient so how can we solve problems
in an enduring way in an equitable way
in a way where nobody really loses
because too often we look at an issue
from a scarcity mindset but frankly we
have an abundant planet and we have
people with so much creativity can we
engage that way differently so that's
what this journey is about awakening the
space within me and within everybody
else and it's about awakening and
articulating what we see through our
pattern mind and third it's about
solving problems through that space it's
not about fixing it and what's amazing
is that people have innate attributes
worldwide and neuroscience and recent
research shows that what we can see is
that human beings have a sense of self
their own self worth which we often you
know talk about as dignity so they have
a sense of self worldwide it doesn't
matter whether we are rich or we're poor
whether we follow any faith or whether
we vote for a particular political party
this transcends all those divides the
social isms that we've created so
basically the sense of self-worth exists
and the sense of fairness exists
worldwide and so very often people ask
me what is it that there's so much
inequity in the world and you say that
we have an innate sense
fairness in fact Oxfam did a study in
the u.s. and they found that 92% of
people actually believed that fairness
is important how great is that so then
people say how come there's so much
inequity I think a lot of the inequity
stems from our understanding of what we
need much of that is promoted through
creating demand for things we actually
don't need through a consumerism that's
extremely materialistic and this work is
about touching that space and this work
is also about the third attribute and
that is compassion what we know now is
that people are not only functioning
from their emotional state what you know
our neuroscientist or a physician will
call our limbic system and our emotional
reactions not that emotion is not
important it's important but we have a
higher consciousness and activating that
consciousness that exists in everyone
everywhere and I can give you many many
stories from around the world about that
when we activate that space of our
higher consciousness we bring to bear
our innate sense of self our sense of
fairness our compassion so compassion
there's a lovely Sanskrit word Sanskrit
is based language of of India and a
Sanskrit word coruña and Karuna means my
my Universal heart of love has broken
open and I'm called to act I cannot just
pass by what's not working and say well
it doesn't serve my personal interest no
I'm called to act so for me tapping into
this spaces worldwide which is our inner
capacity a sense of self our sense of
fairness our knowing of compassion this
has been the way we've created
change worldwide and it's worked we have
results in every sector
[Music]